genius brain listeners this podcast is
brought to you by fume fume my friends
cold turkey may be great on sandwiches
but there's a better way to break your
bad habits we're talking about our
sponsor fume and they look at the
problem in a different way fume is an
Innovative award-winning flavored air
device that does just that instead of
vapor fume uses flavored Air instead of
electronics fume is completely natural
and let me tell you something the feel
is great the look is awesome and I click
click click it away because your boy got
a little bit of ADHD distraction add
stuff so guess what if you're fidgety
awesome so start the holidays off right
with a good habit by going to trif
nume.com genius and getting the journey
packed today fume is giving listeners of
the show 10% off when they use my code
genius to help make starting the good
habit that much easier start the goodh
Habit at
trium.vira asking me about the war in
[__] Palestine and Israel are you out
of your mind in five 4 3 2 1 what's up
everybody welcome to another episode of
The Genius brain podcast we have Ed back
from [__] Seattle cheers cheers you
were in Seattle for a very [__] long
time yeah I kind of go in like months
now in spurts cuz like um the last two
times it was my mom going to Korea again
and then I went back and this time
though it was was so much easier cuz I
actually didn't have to be there like
all the [__] time oh really why not
um cuz my Mom finally hired a competent
employee oh have you ever had one of
those no they're [__] amazing we had
so when my parents had the store right
we tried having a couple of employees
and the two times we had employees they
stole from us and it with clock 100%
100% it's like you they you just have to
factor it in yeah that the like you know
a 20 Buck bill or some [__] 100
something it's going to go missing a
case of beer you know something's going
to go missing my mom's like very
meticulous right so especially when it
comes to a cash business you absolutely
have to be meticulous and we have
cameras in the store yeah so you know it
would be like a month or two AG go buy
things are great and then suddenly $100
missing and my mom's like there's no way
a $100 missing because she's in the
store with them yeah and she's like okay
let me go and you know she'll talk to
them it's like oh you know we blah blah
blah and my dad's like okay we'll check
the cameras and they get nervous and
they don't come back it's like the [__]
man and it sucks too because so when my
parents were doing the store you know at
the time they started hiring uh people
who are like longtime customers like
their kids mhm you know and so we have
rapport with them it's it's dope too
their parents are fine to it and guess
what happens after they steal their
parents come back they drag their
[__] kid in they like give them their
[__] money back oh [__] and it's like
you're never allow don't you ever come
back to the store without me it's like
the only time you're allow in the store
is if I come with you
and they're you know we told them it's
fine they're like no it's not fine they
stole from you so and you know they got
a [__] ass whooping when they got
home or some [__] happened to them but
it sucked my mom's got like a zero
tolerance for like that [__] too I mean
I told you about the the uh employ the
guy who has the lawnmower rides around
lawnmower yeah yeah man that guy man he
uh I I told you about the time like he
just like stole a a [__] case of like
I mean a carton of cigarettes yeah those
are like literally the most expensive
thing you can have at a gas station 100%
yeah especially uh in Seattle cigarettes
are [__] expensive the
taxes when I got back to the store I'm
like this is [__] ridiculous dude so
I started uh I started buying weed right
I had no idea California has like a 30%
tax on [__] weed dude it's so
expensive it is inane cuz I've been
instead of taking gummies I'm just
taking like a like a indicia like Vape
so a little fast it obiously doesn't hit
as hard but it's good enough to help me
fall asleep and then I was checking out
I'm like excuse me like what what is
this and I looked at it a 30% tax on
weed are you insane yeah that's why you
got to go on happy hours that's why
every cannabis store now in La you're
going to have a happy hour where it's
like 20 30% off where you essentially
you're not paying that tax yeah so what
I I didn't know that a lot of these like
weed stores they like firsttime
customers they'll get rid of that 30%
tax so I'm going to different yeah when
they open brand new right yeah I'm doing
that too I'm just doing my rounds yeah
so I got um I forgot what brand it was
but pretty wellknown brand
butzy that's dizzy it's uh it's
something else but uh and I and I just
got a bunch of pre-rolls right I
absolutely hate rolling my own stuff I
don't like it you just get tired there's
like a a like a I don't know there's
just a a kick to it when you do it the
first time like the movies and then you
try to smoke it it looks like [__] it's
[__] falling apart my [__] always
falls apart and you see other people
they're like so meticulous with it I'm
like or I can just get it professionally
done it done and then you're pretty good
to go whatever the [__] you guys had at
Big Bear that [__] Shot Me to the Moon
dude oh yeah and then I remember you're
like just take one puff and I took one
puff and I sat there I was like oh [__]
you guys smoked that whole thing though
yeah that's that's the level of
Tolerance like we've been at dude so
what's that stuff around
the cuz listen
that's ke is like so like you know when
you roll your own stuff you need a
grinder right yeah and then you grind
that [__] and then you put in the well
underneath it there's a second uh
compartment and under it's all that dust
that's that crystal dust on the leaves
that gets you high but when you're
grinding it it falls off right and then
the bottom of it catches it like let's
say you're running out of weed and you
just got a little bit left collect that
[__] put it on top you're going to the
Moon so that's even more potent than the
other stuff crazy potent so these
[__] dip their [__] joints
in wax so also it's so it's covered in a
wax right which is also strong as [__]
and then they use that as a gluing agent
to cover it in ke that makes a lot of
sense so that's where you're just like
yeah when we smoke that you know I have
like the little Vape thing right I took
a couple of Puffs I was like oh it's not
bad and I think it's because the last
time I smoked was that [__] like oh
there's levels to this stuffff there's a
thing about weed like whenever if you
ever have a bad trip you won't have one
again like when you smoke that way again
like your tolerance so crazy dude that
thing was nuts that that boosted my
tolerance to something else because well
whatever Dan has is only that [__] and
so your guys's level of smoking is so
crazy when I started smoking the other
stuff I'm like yeah not so bad but you
got to remember like remember how we
used to drink oh before we discovered
weed mhm
yeah so we're just like I mean even our
doctors are just like yeah go ahead like
rather than bins drinking and getting
[__] up getting blacked out doing God
knows what well that's the thing too for
me for the longest time I didn't want to
smoke weed because I had this weird
thing of like like if I became a dad and
my kid wanted to do drugs it's like well
Dad never did drugs ever and it was
during the time everybody was doing it
right right not anymore papa papa doing
some weed it's like you get it right
well cuz it's either that I don't sleep
yeah right and I know a lot of people
are like well there's other ways to
listen I've done sleep studies sleeping
pills High activity whatever the [__]
that it is and the problem isn't me
getting to sleep it's me sleeping and
staying asleep yeah so uh prior to that
cuz people were telling me that if you
smoke weed you don't get REM sleep then
what the [__] have I been getting cuz
I've been feeling great you feel great
right like I feel rested and I hadn't
felt rested in years so I started taking
like CBD products and uh THC gummies or
whatever for like almost like 5 years 5
six years now so for me though is like I
would I would um like every year I'll
take a break and then maybe I won't
smoke for a couple weeks to a month to
whoever how long right until one day I'm
like yeah I'll do it and you remember
last summer I was off weed for a good
bit and man um here's the truth yes
there's a Clarity yes I'm more active
yes um there's like a focus fact yes
time goes by faster my days go
by I can't sleep yeah and when I do
sleep I have the most [__] up
nightmares yeah my crazy dreams now
here's the thing um that's because I I
suffer from
PTSD So like um The Nightmare part is
just like the [__] that comes with it I
can't do anything about the worst
nightmare that you had I'll tell you one
of mine when I I don't like sativa cuz I
keep getting [__] nightmares and my
nightmares are weird yeah you know what
my [__] nightmare was my nightmare
was I was at a club and there was a club
in Sacramento that closed down right and
the club closed down because a dude got
stabbed to death there and just like
gang violence would happen there all the
time so it was me as an adult now and I
was inside this club that I remember
when I was a kid cuz it was a 18 and
under club uh on the weekdays and 18
over Club on the weekends and so we I
was there and then I was on the wall and
this ugly ass girl was grinding on me
this is my nightmare yeah exactly right
so it's not about monsters and [__]
right it's not like scary stuff it's
like literally your worst case scenario
like possible situation in the real
world you could be in that's adult
nightmares yeah yeah so this girl is
grinding on let me tell this is the
funniest part of this part so she's
grinding on me and for some reason as
she's grinding on me this girl looks
like a creature scaly skin flaky or
whatever just disgusting look if you
look like that in real life I'm sorry
right but monkey pox and then she was
and I'm on the wall like this no like
I'm screaming like stop and then for
some reason as she's grinding she keeps
screaming I'm married it's cool I'm
married and I'm like that doesn't make
sense and so I stop and so she's telling
me she's married and in the nightmare I
go I'm married you can't do this and she
stops she goes you're married you piece
of
[__] so your worst case scenario is just
being gas lito and I'm like what the
[__] are you talking about I was like
it's like you're married too she goes
that's different I'm a [__] woman and
then I'm like freaking out and then
everybody in the club looks at me and
all these women are mad at me oh [__]
like I'm a piece of [__] [__] and I'm
like what the [__] and I'm looking at
them going but she's married too and
they go it doesn't matter you need to be
a better [__] man and then I wake up
yeah I'm like yo this was the worst
[__] nightmare I've ever had in my
life it's just a bunch of women in the
club looking at me for being a piece of
[__] even though I was trying to be
faithful my [__] isn't as funny as yours
but like the way like um it kind of
brings up some like Umma issues too you
know I had a dream my mom shot me in the
head in my sleep and I woke up right and
I'm like what the [__] and it's like my
I can feel my brain and I'm like oh my
God puling huh yeah someone shot me
someone shot me and then this is the
part that's [__] up like
subconsciously I'm going to people like
my mom shot me in my head in my sleep
and they're like no she didn't nuh-uh
come on dude see and I'm like yo what
see in my dream they they were denying
the cheating thing what is that is that
like a habit of weed gaslighting that's
what happens when you smoke we gas yeah
I don't know my dream get I'm getting
gaslighted too about it I'm just like oh
my God have you ever spoken to somebody
about those dreams cuz that's some crazy
[__] I mean here's the thing like yeah I
do weekly therapy and then it's one of
those things where my therapist is just
like that's not my yeah there's like
dream inter or something like that
interpreters but then that's when you
get into the woooo kind of area you know
right you're going to get into that's
where it's like almost astrology it's
too um superstitious like for me too in
my Christian years like it meant
something this is a message from God
yeah right like remember um I told you
about me going to Japan after the
[__] earthquake and tsunami went to
ground zero and all that [__] did I tell
you why I went I don't know I had a
dream
where um
A big flood like tsunami is coming right
and then um the thing is I see me as a
three-year-old like a toddler and I'm
crying and I grab myself and I'm trying
to save myself get to Higher Ground
right and it's [__] fullon Panic
adrenaline rushing everything and I get
to the top of this hill and then the the
flood rers just stop right there at our
feet you you know and then I'm looking
at the the there's like a leaf in the
water and it just dissolves cuz
apparently tsunami is also acid and I'm
like what the [__] and I wake up right
I'm like holy [__] and I'm crying right
and what do I do jump on the internet
check the news [__] massive tsunami
live in Tokyo I'm like oh my God and
this is for me I took it as a sign from
God I was like okay I'm going I'm going
I'm going weird coincidence though yeah
right it's too close for me to not think
that it didn't mean something you know
there's a there's a lot of weird stuff
in relig like you know our friends who
are religious
where it's a little weird I I think
about maybe it's because of the weed now
where you get like kind of introspective
and you think about stuff right because
for me and I've been having
conversations with um other friends
recently about like you know I wouldn't
say it's my departure from like
Christianity right but it's it's me in
the process questioning my faith in my
religion deconstruct and a lot of people
don't like those conversations they
think that when you deconstruct your
religion or you think about your
relationship with God they think that
you're walking away from him right but
for me it's like how I viewed it is how
come you don't question it right well
why don't you think about it because
it's too absolute for them yeah yeah
it's also their entire reality structure
this is why when when I was struggling
through it what I realized was that I
was destroying other people's faiths
that's not fair yeah that's me being
vindictive because I'm mad at
Christianity and that had to do with a
lot of my therapy it's like no I'm mad
at these pastors it's like yeah and then
I got mad at in turn with like the whole
church and at Jesus and at God and the
whole lifestyle and then the idea of me
wasting my life to do some serious
Christian [__] like what the [__] I why
the [__] did I go to Iraq in the middle
of a war you know and it's like crazy
you know after I left Isis took over
blew up that giant Temple of Jonah with
like tons of sticks of dynamite and [__]
oh for real yeah that place where I was
with those people like the Christian
Villages Isis [__] threw them off the
top of buildings murdered them and [__]
that's [__] insane you're this close
to dying yeah like and I did that CU I
love Jesus yeah I did that because I
believe God is real and then if you were
coming to me at like something that
might rock my be
fabric of reality and I'd go crazy yeah
like my everybody's first action is
defense so I had to switch up how do I
bring up these questions and these
conversations to people right yeah and
there's I had to learned there's a line
I can't cross where it's like okay
they're not there they're not going to
question that yet yeah there's very few
people I get to talk to about that and
one of the coolest people right now is
Jason Min from citizens Church sorry
Jason and I haven't been to church in a
while though you know I I lost my New
Year's resolution my buddy uh James who
was on this podcast knows him too they
friends as well yeah so um yeah like I
can have all these conversations with
him and I was so thankful that I could
sit and talk with him about that we're
thinking about you know my Bible study
at M we've been talking about he and I
talk cuz he is a pastor of a very
influential korean-american church here
in La yeah yeah yeah yeah and um he's
one of those pastors that the original
Sovereign Grace original Sovereign gra
they've evolved you know even
theologically you know where they
realize this hardcore Calvinism you know
it's not it maybe that's not the answer
either yeah yeah yeah and so it's a it's
been a great church sorry I haven't been
there but yeah you have to find the
right people to talk to [__] you talk to
me we can maybe branch that [__] off and
do the Bible study at Momo thing but
back to what your question was is like
yeah you got to actually figure out the
right question to ask yeah I it's it's
like one of those things too where um
you know when people
ask where you're so when James was on
this podcast right and we're going to
release a podcast where he touches on
his not departure from God but him going
from Christian music into regular like
rap music right wait James who James Han
James Han uh Sam O's friend your moral
Ed guys no did I tell you I met up with
him yeah yeah you men on the podcast
yeah so we're [__] around now but um
you a lot of people were commenting on
his on on the podcast like you'll read
some of the stuff that's like I don't
know what your journey with God is blah
blah blah but this isn't for me blah
blah blah blah and they're like
gossiping about him in the comments is
this the Uzu Han okay guys I only
listened to like the first like 10
minutes yeah yeah and they were
gossiping about him on his music video
about his faith with Christ and I me
isn't that inherently un Christlike yeah
dude so like I don't understand how that
works how do you guys get into an
digital online group and then you
discuss somebody else his faith and his
departure from God in the worst way
possible you're not doing it to help him
you're not doing it to whatever you view
as a like the right way of Christianity
whatever that version is you're doing
that to bring this guy down to beat him
down to lift him up I don't understand
the point of this
coincidentally it is happening in the
same time to a another artist Lil Nas X
you see his latest clip no he
said I'm going into my Christian era and
he singing like a Christian song what he
wrote a Christian song and it's not
bad really it's a song him like reaching
out to God like I got these issues they
tell me only you can solve this you you
know what's crazy we but he got so much
hate why from other celebrities too
other rappers other like they're saying
yo first you mock God and now you want
to be act all Christian you can't you
can't do that yes you can and it's like
hey do we want them to be Christian or
not yeah what are you asking for exactly
like what the [__] do Christians want in
America today yeah I think they want to
keep their group however the [__] they
want it you know and like the they want
their culture yeah they want their
nuclear family they want it the way it
was or it used to be or whatever yeah
but hey let's go back to the way it was
when Jesus was alive yeah the way it
used to be yeah without any running
water where you got stoned to death on
the street yeah I I don't think you guys
want it like that dude like what are you
guys talking about this way of life and
this culture and then you look at Jesus
and everything he's doing he's breaking
culture they're like yo Jesus we don't
do that he's like I do yeah and he
changed it I mean for for for somebody
like Lil NAX right I mean you probably
if you are I mean the biggest issue was
for him or what people you know have
problems with with him was his basically
celebration of the devil right and then
if he's going to flip that around and
praise God then you basically your
prayers have come true right but now you
have an issue because he's becoming the
face of Christianity well at the time
like for me anyways if I if if he can
get if I'm you know a hardcore Christian
right and he can get talk to the youth
and saying that oh this is the way I was
before and there was something wrong
here and I found God isn't that what you
want yeah
is are you upset because you weren't
that person yeah is because you're not
getting the glory is that why you're
upset it's just a little hypocritical I
don't understand what the point of that
is the point is that modern day
Christians don't know what the [__] to
do yeah and they act like they do and
they shouldn't they should just [__]
say they don't know what to do rather
than choosing to sin yeah instead of
doing the Christlike thing you know what
you're supposed to do you're supposed to
love him you're supposed to love them I
I was I had a conversation with a buddy
of mine and you know he was talking to
me about you know some of the podcast
stuff that we talk about in Christian he
was like do you feel like you know he
wasn't being mean about it you know I
think he does feel a certain way yeah um
but he was like do you feel like you as
somebody who you know you tell me you're
Christian but you have these
conversations about the stuff that you
went through do you think that deters
people from Christianity I was like I
don't know if it necessarily deters
people from Christianity but it is stuff
that happened so I choose to talk about
it cuz maybe it's therapy for me right
so you know I'm glad that your your walk
in Christ and whatever the hell happened
to you was great whatever the hell
happened to you whatever whatever the
heavens happened whatever the hell
happened to you was all fantastic but my
walk wasn't as great as yours right I
went through a lot of [__] specifically
in a church that was very corrupt and
nobody ever talked about the stuff and
we always brush things under the rug and
every time we do that nothing gets
better well guess what when I talk about
this stuff other people speak up in
their own churches and they start being
like hey this is wrong oh and they start
talking to other people people we
shouldn't do this anymore so I think
people are just very good at sweeping
things under the rug and they act like
everything's okay because they're so
scared that somebody's going to look at
their church or Christianity in a bad
way well guess what if you don't
confront that problem now it's never
going to change yeah it's never going to
change people are going to continue to
be shitty [__] people they're going
to be power hungry and no and everybody
goes and checked it's the same thing
that happens in Hollywood right
everybody sweeps under things under the
rug just so they can get an opportunity
and nothing ever [__] changes that's
why hate these [__] stupid Galas what
the gold Gala or whatever the [__] that
shit's called what's the Asian one
called it's the Asian masturbation award
yeah it's basically what it is right and
they're basically perpetuating the stuff
that they say in Hollywood but they're
doing it themselves just in a different
group with different faces so I I don't
agree with that stuff at all and you
know if anybody who's a part of that
wants to sit here and have a
conversation with me oh we could talk
for days cuz I've been to that thing and
I've heard every single one of those
[__] actors in that group sit and say
nice things to somebody's face and they
go to some other group and they start
talking [__] about that person at the
same [__] event yeah you're you're
you're psychotic you guys are [__]
crazy the weird thing is like it's also
a bunch of dweebs acting
way it's not like your Brad pits and
that [__] it's like dweet yeah it's like
what is the point of this [__] dude it's
so [__]
dumb you know but even now like we you
know to go back to that little nasx
thing like we're we're we're finding I
don't know why this is happening but we
we are finding a lot of people going
back towards like Protestant ideals and
Christianity yes a lot of people they're
talking about God they're talking about
oh this way that I've been doing things
this whole Anarchist idea has left me
feeling terrible and now I'm going this
way I don't know why yeah dude and you
know who's help bringing it towards the
mainstream the UFC the UFC man come on
every [__] Saturday night I want to
say thank you to Jesus I want to say
thank you to my Jesus yeah or like hey
first things first all glory to God you
know it's like there's a thing with
athletes uh where um in order for them
to Humble themselves because to be a
[__] Champion you have to believe
you're a God yeah in a sense yeah but
then someone like a Jon Jones or whoever
they got to say there's this higher
power than me too while I might be
ruling this I think that's how these men
culturally you know check themselves
then you got a kabib a defa Muslim you
know what's interesting like
it's it's religion I don't think it's
just Christianity there's like yo
there's the ways of the old that keeps
us in check yeah and then it's part of a
thing masculine thing cuz we're doing
something so Primal in watching people
combat or you know people who are
fighting right and when we do that we
just like think of ourselves in the days
of old and our ancestors who did this
too yeah yeah yeah you know you know and
we we've been seeing it now too where
like I think people are really getting
to see how powerful religion is like in
a good and a bad way right like when we
talk about the like we haven't I haven't
spoken about this on this podcast just
because I just don't know right and
we've talked about it too where it's
just it's such a complicated topic that
a lot of people want to dumb down and
say it's very simple right it's the
issue that's happening with like Israel
and Palestine I don't know how many
messages that I've got of people coming
at me saying why aren't you speaking up
and I'm like let me tell you something
here you [__] simpleton [__] genius
brain listeners this podcast is brought
to you by fume cold turkey may be great
on sandwiches but there's a better way
to break your bad habits we're talking
about our sponsor fume and they look at
the problem in a different way not
everything in a bad habit is wrong so
instead of drastic uncomfortable change
why not just remove the bad from your
habit fume is an innovated award-winning
flavored air device that does just that
instead of vapor fume uses flavored Air
instead of electronics fume is
completely natural and it's instead of
harmful chemicals fume uses delicious
flavors you get it instead of bad fume
is good it's a habit you're free to
enjoy and makes replacing your bad habit
easy your fume comes with an adjustable
airflow dial and is designed with
movable parts and magnets for fidgeting
which is pretty awesome for me because
your boy is fidgety as hell the wood on
it is super nice has a really great feel
and look if like I said if you have a
bad habit not everything in a bad habit
is bad so why not just take the bad out
of the Habit start the holidays off
right with the good habit by going to
trif nume.com genius and getting the
journey packed today fume is giving
listeners of the show 10% off when they
use code genius to help make starting
the good habit that much easier start
the good habit at tri.com genius to save
10% off the journey pack today like do
you think it's an easy conversation for
me to bring up on an hour podcast where
I literally speak about the death and
murder of children like a war that has
been happening for years and you want me
to simplify within an hour somebody who
lives in the comfort of this podcast in
this seat in the United States what the
[__] do I know right what can I add to
this conversation it's like you should
say that children dying are bad hey no
[__] no no [__] [__] you think
anybody's arguing that fact you think
anybody's arguing the fact that what's
happening right now is an atrocity you
think that if I said something now it
hasn't been said a million times over
that that event that happened that that
happened the bombing of that hospital is
one thing that happened over a a period
of like 75 years yes that is not the
first that's what's so irritating about
this [__] youth you think that that
was the impetus it was not the impetus
yeah [__] happened a long time ago you
may argue it happened 1,500 years ago
not just 75 and they want somebody like
me this [__] idiot who has a podcast
called genius brain born from the
opposite side of the world grew up on
the even further opposite side of the
world let's talk about what's happening
there but like while it's being the it
is the largest news no they want you to
join their side exactly not like talk
about it because I wouldn't even be
listen and I did think about doing a
podcast on this but there was so much
history I had to read read about ask so
many questions I left more jumble than I
did before right and once again we're
not talking about the death of innocent
people that is a consensus that
everybody doesn't want that to happen
like you're at a point where you get it
every time someone says it's complicated
yeah cuz you looked into it and now if
someone El wants to ask you you're like
[__] it's complicated this is the
annoying part if you say it's
complicated you know what the response
is how is the death of children
complicated it's like that is you're so
stupid it blows my [__] mind they're
looking at the elephant an inch away
from their face yeah that's what it is
yeah that's exactly what it is and like
for me to kind of just boil this topic
down into like an hour like I said
before it's so stupid and you know
Selena Gomez she got she had to delete
her Instagram for a second because she
put out a statement say people saying
like why aren't you saying stuff about
this she goes because as a celebrity if
I say something what can I do and then
people [__] went in on her called her
a monster they try to [__] her up online
it was so bad but literally I just
remember not that long ago they said you
know what if you're an actor just
[__] act don't talk about politics
and she did that and she still got
flamed this is how stupid this [__] is
and do you know what the number one song
in Israel is right now apparently it's a
song about killing and [__] up
American celebrities for speaking out
this is you know what I'm saying yeah
it's like even if you did would you make
it on it's like what what's the purpose
what is this game right look what's
happening let's like try not to play the
game for a sec right let's look at let's
look at this whole [__] map oh by the
way apparently nobody gives a [__] about
Ukraine
anymore yeah we forgot and we completely
forgot about those ukrainians that we
gave billions of dollars to in fact we
couldn't fund them in their last rounds
of asking for money because of what's
happening there and now apparently the
reports are a lot of Russian investment
you know so [__] is even more
complicated like this is a very this is
affecting a completely different War so
there's it's just so hard to say I don't
know what the solution is because over
here in the United States they just put
a sign we want peace
okay no [__] CE fire now yeah I'm man I
hope they can hear
you well that's the other thing too I
was talking to my buddy who's who's
Jewish and he's like the hard part for
like Jewish people here is that you know
we're I'm I'm Jewish and you're going to
feel for your people yeah but I'm a
Jewish American I don't know what it's
like over there and it's hard for me and
he can't even say this on his own
platform like on stuff he goes I just
what I want to say is like you know for
us as like a Jewish American Community
here we're so far away from that
conflict we actually don't know what
it's like to live there yeah right we
don't know what it's like in Gaza we
don't know what's happening over there
we just know that we feel something for
our people and if I even show a little
bit of empathy towards Palestinians
because they're human beings my people
will [__] [__] me up they'll call me
a traitor they'll call me all these
other things and I can't even say
anything because now that you've seen
this there has been so
many like anti- Palestine [__] so many
anti-semitic [__] that's popping up it's
terrible dude yeah it's so [__] bad
and this is stuff that I you maybe it's
because of the weed once again where I
think about this a lot right I'm like I
don't know what the solution is for them
I just don't want it to happen and
that's where I feel so stupid if I go
out and I go on Instagram and I go hey
ceasefire all right David what next yeah
you know and do you think this is people
like who are angry at you they keep
convoluting social media for real life
yeah that likes and content affects real
life somebody even said this they're
like well you did that for Maui [__]
there was a direct place where you could
deposit the families there was an
immediate solution give money to the
families who lost their home here are
their venos there was a direct solution
we're talking about war yeah this isn't
this isn't a natural disaster that
happened we're talking about war
people's lives people are being shot
killed murdered and bombed what are you
talking about David where's your gun
where's your boots why aren't you
strapped up like why aren't you on the
next flight this is what I'm saying and
like I I think
that a lot of social media people got
smarter because in the beginning EV you
I saw it the same people that I saw they
were like [__] Palestine and then a
month later it went free Palestine yeah
like I was like hold on a second here
you know what I mean and you could have
a change of heart or whatever but you
were coming at people yeah cuz they
weren't holier than thou like you were
they weren't the ones that were out
there they call it the front lines the
front lines you're making an Instagram
post all right so this makes me think
about
911 I was in in 11th grade or you 9th
grade yeah yeah I
remember my first my home class was
video production and so the teacher had
a big giant TV screen and the News was
on World Trade Centers One's On Fire and
I walk in and I I said what movie is
this right they're like it's not a movie
holy [__] cuz my school started so
[__] early it was like 6:30 or 7:00
in the morning and so I'm watching this
happen and then
literally second plane goes
in we were watching it on the on TV they
rolled out the TV and we were watching
right like and if you hear what all
these Israeli people and like even the
their prime minister Benjamin nanahu um
which we won't get into him cuz he's got
got a whole another political bag of
[__] there's some crazy [__] about that
guy we're not we don't have time to talk
about this [__] yeah like yeah like what
what it makes me think is what America
happened to America afterwards yeah like
a lot of kids born after 911 have no
idea of that America before 911 it was a
different country yeah damn near and
especially the response that was
happening was how what what they were
telling us right
was support our troops that was the
model wasn't it for years support our
troops support our troops support our
troops War let's go war war war and we
were all for it for sure I'm older now
and we're seeing this terrorist attack
and I remember those days cuz you I've
told a million times I grew up in this
rural all white town and they were and
were like why do they do this and
they're just like cuz they hate us yeah
you know cuz they have to live with sand
in their ass so there was a time before
guys when you were on a plane and you
didn't have to take off your shoes at
TSA you're you could take someone to the
airport
go right all the way up to the game say
goodbye yeah not anymore that changed
literally right after 9/11 like kids
don't remember that [__] like all the
the metal detectors the screenings the
TSA all of that [__] and it actually
gotten a little more relaxed cuz I think
for years it it was hard get to the
airport 5 hours early y it was like that
they were that scared it was crazy too I
remember there was a guy who was a he's
a buddy of mine still a good friend of
mine he was Hardcore atheist this is
this [__] started praying so
much like oh my God yeah I mean I told
you like I met a guy in Iraq another
white dude was a missionary who went
there because on 9/11 he became
Christian yeah it changed the world like
the way people looked so now if you get
into the shoes of these sensitive
freaked out anxious people of attacks
cuz shortly afterwards Anthrax happened
yes too and then what happened we
[__] invaded Iraq and had nothing to
do with
9/11 and you have to look at what these
these countries now are looking at and
and want to do they don't want a
two-state solution yeah on both sides
and the whole world is like guys settle
down that was a thing that I didn't know
about like until I started listening to
a bunch of podcasts and interviews of
pro Palestinian and pro pro Israeli and
once again I'm not St cuz I don't I
don't live there so I don't know but
that is the one thing that was in common
there is no two-state solution they want
none of it and I was I was actually
shocked I'm like oh cuz you know from a
simpleton's point of view I'm like can
you guys split it is there a way that we
could divide land no because one people
I'm anoint we are anointed by God this
is given to us right this is my land yes
and I didn't know any of that [__] you
know and I see I watch these videos of
multiple I'm talking about I've probably
seen hundreds of videos and it's that
same argument God says this is mine yeah
Allah says this is mine you're on my
land this is God given this is Allah's
land he said it is given to our people
you are invading us yeah but this is our
land given by God there is no two-state
solution here either you leave or we
leave or you die or I die and that [__]
scary that shit's [__] frightening
and you're seeing what's happening and
we said it before so why is America so
invested in it why are we in that [__]
so hard and I mentioned it last time
because we got a bunch of
evangelicals who think they know what
the Bible says and are looking forward
to the end of the world because of what
the Book of Revelation says and [__] I
just find it really fascinating like on
our end where how can people who live
who have lived in the comfort of the
United States even fathom or pretend to
know what people are going through over
there you don't know which is but it's
the same thing though it's their same
god-given entitlement that the end on
the world's coming and it's like hey you
on this train you on this end of the
world train and so they're like they
want our government to help destroy you
know Hamas not just Hamas but like
literally Arabs literally Mecca
literally like just and it's like why
are you even inserting this into this so
you're taking this opportunity in this
war to insert like American nationalism
and imperialism and into your
Christianity but also because you want
to end the world yeah you want the
apocal you want it all over like I
that's the crazy part about why you know
the the parts of Christianity where I'm
just like I'm not part of that you know
what's like interest I want to say the
word is interesting is how sad it is for
I you know someone like me I didn't
understand what was happening in Gaza
yeah I just didn't know it existed you
know what I'm saying you know what's
crazy too they [__] all the places
are bombing out and [__] historical
biblical places you know yeah they don't
give a [__] cuz it's War to them and
they're like isn't this special to you
too yeah this land you know it's weird
cuz you know I'm seeing these back and
forth from a lot of people and I'm just
observing it to see what's going on and
the people who are arguing are like I
said people who live here right who
aren't Palestinian Middle Eastern or
Jewish they're just yelling at each
other but it's like none of you are
doing anything the imperialism idea it's
like it is our responsibility to go save
these people you know but how right it's
like people are yelling at Biden that
you know diplomatically America has a
relationship with Israel to be like
ain't nobody going to destroy Israel
yeah you know we it
but it's like in this part it's
like honestly they can't ask us for more
weapons cuz all the weapons are American
weapons yeah like America gives billions
and billions you know to the state of
Israel you know we our tax dollars had a
huge hand in building the Gaza Strip
yeah and partitioning it you know that's
what's happening and so understandbly
that's why people are mad like hey like
we''ve been living living Our Lives
blind to it but then that money we give
up every year a part of it is going to
kill God and God I mean Palestinian
people you know it's understandably
they're angry right this is why it's
like what can we do yeah what can you do
from here it's like when War happens
people suffer the most right and then I
I keep seeing these videos cuz I can't
turn my cheek to it I can't not see it
because it's happening and you just see
people in Israel
these children dying and then you look
over at these Palestinians their
children are dying they're crying I'm
like I don't I don't know what to do
here that's another thing over half the
population is aged like 8 to 18 yeah
kids kids half the population and have
you seen the videos of them bombing yeah
it's those are kids children I you see
kids missing their limbs are missing and
I'm talking about four-year-olds
threeyear olds twoy olds and it's just
they bombed Bethlehem too like Jesus's
birthplace and all that [__] yeah dude
that's jesus' Hometown dude yeah it's
like [__] it's it's kind of crazy man
um how like what how poisonous like
religious fervor yeah can be right when
somebody believes in something so hard
like the lives of other people are like
devalued is [__] insane and I just
can't imagine myself doing that right
but then like I said it's just from my
perspective living here here so it's
it's just a weird thing when other
celebrities are trying to out other
celebrities for not doing what they feel
that they should do yeah right it's just
like I said it's an oversimplified
solution for a complicated subject and I
just i' I've seen other YouTubers you
know they doing this podcast just
talking pure nonsense you know what I'm
saying where we have people online who
are Scholars right that are trying to
break down down this conflict and even
then they say it's a complicated topic
and a subject yeah but then you have
some of these YouTubers some of these
podcasters like let's talk about this
because it's a Hot Topic you are going
to [__] hell just to put it out there
you're going to hell you need some time
you you you need Jesus dude like you saw
this thing happen you saw videos of like
people being murdered and you went Hot
Topic let's talk about I'm people drop
podcast on this thing when when that
hospital was bombed I'm talking about 2
days after and they had an opinion about
it yeah it's like are you are you so
morally corrupt that that you thought
that was the move I mean at this point
though do you have like an opinion about
it like what you think and feel about it
that you're ready to share it's like
yeah like for me it's like I'm just at a
point where I'm asking questions yeah
and I want to hear other people's
perspective for people who have
experienced lived and they know what's
going on right cuz it would be I would
be a li to say that I could explain
what's happening within even four five
six seven podcast I I am not the one and
nor do I feel comfortable talking about
stuff like that right because it has
nothing to do with anything that I know
about so I don't have the confidence and
I also think that it's just I don't know
something inside me just doesn't feel
right right but when I see other people
on this platform just use that as a
thing for them to get likes and clicks
hey do that with celebrity gossip yeah
yeah do that with Kanye and Kim's
[__] relationship that's happening
you I mean little nasx no longer sucking
dick that's fine yeah you know it's like
no let's talk about war like o did she
hear what Israel dude yeah like that
[__] like I mean like seriously it's
not like that right there are people in
my circle who I saw that and I was like
just going to tell you I lost a little
little bit of a lot of bit of respect
for you you know yeah like you just
choose a side like right off the bat and
you actually don't know what it's about
like cuz yes Face Value the terrorist
attack is terrible and then the worst
thing you can do is sympathize with a
terrorist right but the
most I tell you the most WIS thing to do
is give it a shot why would this
[__] strap a fan on his back and
parachute in and just kill these kids
well that was the the thing that you
know for somebody who like myself who
wanted to see what was happening right
cuz we've heard of Hamas for a long time
right but then I go back to this word
impetus what caused Hamas to form right
and I just didn't know I I didn't know
what was happening it was and then when
I looked into it it was all that [__] I
didn't understand when I was in fifth
grade that was just on the news all the
time you know and like Bill Clinton
getting these two brown people to shake
hands I'm like cool yeah you know and
then from there it was actually those
peace talks failed yeah yeah and then
you know and then there's there's a
timeline of the [__] of where it comes
to nobody wants to go that far back
because actually requires for you to
research it actually requires for you to
think for yourself and it's it's look I
understand it's tiring but if it's not
tiring enough for you to make this
[__] 30- minute like [__] podcast
video about the very complicated subject
you could have gone back and at least
looked at that right because it's a very
serious topic and so you know when we
looked at that like you can't even say
this if you if like even on this podcast
I'm pretty sure there's going to be
comments coming at me where I go where I
literally said I wonder why Hamas exists
and they go so you support them it goes
from that to that I hate that [__] dude
it's like what what the [__] so if I if
I if I ask a question it aut
automatically means I'm supporting this
terrorist organization for me I'm like
why it doesn't take the fact that I
think they're terrible yeah you know but
but we have to ask why like where did
these people come from why do they feel
this way and why is it like this
like you you got to ask yourself what
would it take for me to do some crazy
[__] like that well if somebody
literally took my family home that my
great-grandfather built with his own
hands and and they kicked me out and
they got some dude just living in there
and then in the
meantime uh they killed my kids and then
they killed my wife and then they killed
my sister
and then I went to a peaceful
protest and I every day for two years
and then they shot my legs out and now I
can't
walk might be a little mad I'm be mad I
mean this is what like white Americans
can understand too man like and like
what exercising the Second Amendment is
it do yeah like I said and that once
again people hear you say that they're
like he loves Hamas yeah right like come
on
okay here's another thing then Attack on
Titan just finished did you see it
that's basically it's this yeah if you
can see how [__] complicated War gets
because of how much you hate somebody
for some [__] somebody did a thousand
years ago or or maybe a while ago or
whatever it'll never end yeah it will
never end and then on the other side too
you can now see what happened what was
it October 7th yeah on October 7th
how this bombing that happened people in
Israel right whoever was attached their
children were murdered in this hospital
and they that's their experience of what
happened now you can see while there'll
be like Islamic extremists as well
because they're going to take that raise
from what they felt from this wrongdoing
that happened and it's going to create
this hate only allows for other hate to
happen it's just going to continue to
grow yeah over and over and over again
dude and that that leads to like you
know what people are raving about for
war though like here's what Koreans
understand um like South Koreans hate
Communists they really hate them you
know yeah and they we had a whole War
about it and we're still actually
technically at War about it
right so you know I remember I mentioned
before that my grandfather was in
Vietnam you know not as an American
Soldier as a Korean Soldier you know and
I knew just the bit historically that
when America went into Vietnam like
Korea was like Hey W go will be there
right because of what America had done
for in Korea South Korea in the Korean
War and I
youtubed Koreans in Vietnam War and it's
War crime war crimes war crimes war
crimes war crimes and I'm like holy [__]
my h is a war
criminal it's like the only reasons
Koreans went and they only spit scent
there like
absolute did you see that one clip of uh
Bobby and Andrew Santino where Bobby's
like Korean people never had
slaves world record for
long Kore like the longest period of
slavery over any Nation like, 1500 years
likey slaved each other it's different
dude that's why classism is so hardcore
in Korea but yeah I mean
that's there's like all these things
like I realized I sat down with M my
cousin visit Washington when I was up
there too I was like yo I just looked up
this thing like my grandfather was in
Vietnam and she goes your grandfather's
a war criminal like she already
knew if I say Korean and Vietnam it's
like yeah they were immediately
immediately yeah so the testimonies from
the Viet Kong about Koreans is [__] up
that's crazy cuz all I dat it was
Vietnamese girls
so that's crazy how our generation
doesn't know anything about this we
didn't know about that right and then I
look at myself like I get all salty at
Japanese people about not knowing about
World War II [__] you know dude uh so I
actually watched um an early release of
the boy in the Heron ah [__] I'm going
to see that this Sunday yeah I watched
an early release of it and it you know
it's it's it's a Coming of Age story
it's about um World War II and you know
and interestingly enough I spoke to Joe
Joe just a c and he spoke about his
grandmother right and his
grandmother doesn't know anything about
the war and here's the reason why and
you're going to see the story of Joe
it's basically the story of Joe's
grandma and boy in the her so a lot of
like Japanese Elites who had money they
didn't experience the war they took
their money in their wealth and they
just hid in the mountains until the war
was over and so you're going to see that
in this and I was like holy [__] that's
exactly what Joe said about his grandma
and you're going to see that in this
film so there was like people who were
at Ground Zero when all this stuff was
happening right but rich people rich
people don't experience [__] they just
go away and they come back whenever you
know when everything's cool yeah
especially like people who were like in
like in the industrial uh a part of like
that Industrial Revolution in Japan
where they were supplying military stuff
like uh steel work like metal work like
those they were very wealthy during the
war they were profiting off of the war
so just making a [__] ton of money and
they just kind of lived off in the
mountain side and did whatever the [__]
that they wanted and you're going to see
that in this film yeah I mean I'm all
for it it's like this this is what we
had this conversation with Oppenheimer
people wanting to see Japanese people
get blown to
Smither like hey here's the movie for
that there's a little side of the the
story it's like let them create and
they'll see it and like have you seen it
yet Oppenheimer no okay you're coming
over my place [__] okay but yeah like
you know what when you ask people like
us what can we do and stuff like that
it's like we tell the stories yeah you
know if we can be here and let you guys
know what's going on like deep into the
character of it even if you don't want
to even if you don't want to understand
terrorists you don't want to understand
a murderer you know but you love
watching True Crime for some reason
anyway you know but seriously like um
there's an old not old I can't believe I
said that but there's movie syriana uh
George Clooney it's like it's like the
series of um stories with people
interconnecting and that has to do with
um this event that happens in the Middle
East of terrorism right and it follows
all these different characters and that
leads towards this big thing and it's
like you even follow a young you know
Muslim boy and you see see how they
become medicalized yeah you take all
their [__] away from them I mean people
are asking right now why is Gen z boys
turning more conservative why are they
listening to Andrew Tate and all that
[__] it's
like hey if you take away these certain
things and accessible things or whatever
they're going to look to something that
gives them hope yep and I always talk I
I'm pretty sure you guys are tired of me
saying this but I think you guys are
finally coming around to what I'm saying
I told you you swing that [__] pendulum
hard this way what's going to happen
it's going to swing back swing right the
[__] back and you're seeing it right now
right it's just I don't know history
constantly repeats itself over and over
and over and you would think people will
be smart enough to pick up on this trend
but when you're in it they don't and now
young people now are so easy to be make
them like radicalized we see like a we
like for a hot second before this before
the conservative movement is starting to
happen now what was it communism and
socialism was popping dude oh God
everybody was like socialism light
Bernie and and then like capitalist
socialism through Andrew y yeah you know
it's like well at least for Andrew Yang
it seemed a bit
pragmatic like but yeah I mean like The
Swinging hard back is is just like these
young boys looking at also looking at
these dudes that our culture today is
like when we look at genx white dudes
and say you ain't relevant yeah we don't
care what you say none of that [__]
there was this video of this one guy he
was like a Russian dude and he was just
like talking he goes I don't think you
guys understand what's what communism is
you know it's like this is this is the
dumbest conversation I'm having here
it's like why why do I somebody who
escaped communism have to tell you how
bad this is yeah you know you guys
idolize this ideal but you don't know
what it's like they they need to a
better word at structuring like what the
idea is yeah yeah or give it give it a
better named like what Bernie does is
calling it Democratic socialism we vote
for it hey do you want to pay more taxes
for this yeah it's it's that basically
and other nations do it but when we do
it cuz we're America we say no that's
communism and we can go in circles and
circles all you can do is just vote yeah
and then we sit here and we see the way
the [__] waves turn and we'll just
talk about it we observe we're the
Watchers we're not like the leaders or
else you guys would vote for us yeah but
instead you guys quote unquote vote in
your way of just you know berating your
guys' favorite influencers to believe
what you believe to vote for you yeah
like I'm saying too like don't ever look
towards an influencer to tell you where
your moral compass should go are you out
of your [__] mind I literally stuff
my pants with two socks the other day
and I put it on my Instagram feed and
you're asking me about the war in
[__] Palestine and Israel are you out
of your mind a video of you and your
unies a huge chunk go to comment section
free Palestine yeah I I got couple
though this girls was like you know
what's happening in Palestine are are
you [__] out of your
mind who are you asking yeah like what
honestly for me is like if what my hope
is for people listening or watching is
that just take a Humane approach yeah
just be Humane you know that there are
human beings and if you're a Christian
too honestly both sides the eyes of
Jesus and all of them come on guys like
loving them loving your enemy like
getting to that part is like the hardest
thing for Christians and they refuse
yeah they refuse to love did you see
this report I forget what article if it
was New York Times or something but
there is an issue in American churches
today where um like you said there's
Christianity is popping back in in
American culture so dudes are deciding
to go back to church right but they're
hearing a pastor say to turn the other
cheek blessed are the meek pray quietly
you know yeah don't be a jackass yeah
love your enemy and then these new
Christians are like hey man I that's
soft it's in the Bible it's like that's
Jesus like that's the other thing that
people need to understand all these
[__] Christians who want us to keep
sending these billions like to preserve
Israel or whatever you know Jesus
predicted that is Israel would be no
more well they don't want to talk about
that they don't want to talk about that
like and it's like one of the biggest
events Jesus finally getting to
Jerusalem after just trekking all of it
like the land and what what does he do
when he gets in there to fulfill the
prophecy doesn't find a cult he gets a
donkey you know and then they're all
saying Hosanna Hosanna Hosanna and then
they lay the palm trees at his feet to
honor him most modern Christians don't
read the Bible though they don't read
the Bible but then this is the thing
like his disciples perspective they're
like holy [__] he they love him they
they haven't seen him yet they heard of
him like he is the Messiah yeah and and
they're like Jesus isn't this awesome
and he's like you know what he says he's
like man if these guys didn't say
anything the Rocks would cry out yeah
he's like he do care yeah he didn't so
and then he gets in they're like they
see the temple of Solomon they're like
oh my God Jesus look at this this is
amazing and then he says you know all of
this like it's going to be gone it's
going to be destroyed Stone from Stone
all of it's going to be gone right and
they're like what are you talking about
yeah and then he says look at that lady
over there and he sees a poor lady give
her only two cents that's all she had
and she gave it
you know in her offering and he says
that's [__] crazy people read that
verse and always use it as a way to make
people give more offering yeah right
that's not what he meant yeah he's like
that's crazy just like all those
televangelists that pray on old white
women that ask for their government
checks and like their money that they
were going to give to their children for
inheritance they they give it to these
[__] televangelist it's like people
who use therapy to weaponize like they
take things out of cont it's the same
thing that was happening Jesus called
that [__] out 2000 years ago too what is
like the one of the biggest misquoted
Bible verses and it was years ago where
um it was mentioned about the
whole was it it was like a it was the
blood is thicker than water right but
the whole scripture is not blood is
thicker than water there's this whole
thing at the end where it basically
explains that that's [__]
yeah I mean like your bonds that you
have with people mean more than this
familial bond that you have yeah right
it's like the families that you create
and the bonds that you create will be
stronger tie than the thing that ties
you with blood but then people only took
that one little piece and they kept
using it against people right and you
see it happen over and over again that
point where all that was was to say
Christians like I'm not saying you're
not supposed to care but like he said it
was all going to go away and then keep
reading about what he says about what
matters yeah what matters
is the people it's the people it's not
the land it's not the
buildings it's the
suffering it's the
widows it's the
orphans it's the homeless now it is the
dying it's the sick all of that yet the
Christians of America today just want
more war and you I'm just saying go read
it again in The Book of Mark like check
it out he's like talks about this war
[__] he he describes all that too it's
like guys love the people that are there
love your neighbors love your enemies
that's what he's asking for that there's
your solution there's how you do it
that's how you peace yeah but they don't
want to read the Bible you don't want to
do that so it's okay you don't want to
read it so it's all right well guys that
wraps up this episode of The Genius
brain podcast I know we're going to have
a lot of [__] hate on this one uh
write in the comments below about your
thoughts about this podcast uh like I
said I don't know what's going on and as
an influencer who stuffs his pants for
Content I don't feel comfortable talking
about it so um see yall next time genius
Sprint every Sunday at 12 pm. secret
society is s c r TS o c IE ty.com uh you
can go ahead and cop your highquality
fashion basic there Juni matcha once
again check out my store in y ke ke and
also we're expanding the brand I think
we'll have probably hopefully a total of
15 stores next year so and uh check out
my gas station in Washington State
all right
peace